je rappelle quand même pour une maladie
comme la rougeole qui tue considéré
comme une maladie infantile entre 2000
2008 et 2012 à peu près il ya eu 23 1000
cas de rougeole il y a eu dix décès mais
ce sont dix décès de trop pour une
maladie qui peut être totalement
évitez-vous cas en italie et l'allemand
eon roumaine en représente pour des
enfants
la disparition d'enfants qui ne devrait
devrait pas avoir lieu alors ces
maladies sont potentiellement éradiquée
mais exactement
donc je rappelle les pays aurait
beaucoup d'autres exemples qu'on
pourrait donner donc l'échangé des
bonnes pratiques est certainement
quelque chose de d'efficace néanmoins il
y à des cultures différentes
les français sont toujours des frondeurs
et il suffit qu'on leur impose quelque
chose pour qu'ils aient tous les doutes
sur ce qu'on va leur imposer
et ça c'est regrettable quand il s'agit
de vaccination parce que c'est quand
même ça concerne la santé la santé de
leurs enfants la santé de la population
donc c'est grave dans ce cas là